did you do this one I think so I'm going
to put my finger over this hole mm-hmm
light it back in yeah and then when I'm
ready I move my fingers off there okay I
think I'm ready at all yeah one time
when I first smoked meat I didn't suck
in and I was just slowly burning my
flesh I still to this day have issues
with these things no boy what no that
was just you got a big hit there oh I
got scared when you called it big what
do you think about this case man I think
Warren's of shady dude he's got shady
eyebrows he's got the eyebrows of a
villain you're right he's got the sort
of the jawline and the overall size of
like a gas doll from I bet you you know
eating the Beast
he doesn't like a girl who reads no no
got like just one line of teeth I don't
wanna I don't wanna judge him entirely
on his his appearance he's also weird
yeah but I think that that wasn't the
wisest purchase for their family because
for example I have bought a car before
well I would have never been paid
$47,000 for it she kind of rolled her
eyes when I said $47,000 car-like yeah
it's kind of crazy but it's like also
yeah but you're still doing it you're
still trying to buy for you some of
those $8 car and you're talking to the
shady you know character played by putty
from Seinfeld what is happening like
that should give a deposit and not get
the truck that's all we know I was again
that $2,000 he was like this and that of
course with that was he was also
flirting with me yeah hmm listen I don't
think he's a bad guy but how do you feel
about being tied to train track
[Music]